and you know you know what I'm tired so
women we have this beauty right so when
we get into the workforce we have an
advantage over men we have an advantage
over men in dating because as a young
woman you're born with value you are
born beautiful now some women will use
this beauty to go into say
sales some women use this beauty to go
into professional sports I mean some
women use this beauty I mean I wouldn't
recommend that there's not a lot of
money there but but okay um some women
use this beauty to go into nursing
assistant roles now it's not to say that
there's no brains that come with this
but you're more likely to be hired than
a guy and one way that women are using
this beauty and this money-making
machine is through only fans now right
now guys we're in an epidemic because if
you include camw work and only fans
there are
more only fans workers then teachers
that it's a more common profession for
women under the age age of 35 this new
generation of women it's more common and
you know what I'm really tired of this
is why I am sick and tired of the
bitching and
moaning women in their early 20s that
are so willing to do porn and only fans
for quick money and attention they're so
willing to do it and then crying
bitching and whining about it later so
there's a woman named Becca TV now I
don't know who this chick is never heard
of her in my life but she exposes
predatory only fans agencies for
complete robbery so let me get this
straight you signed a
contract and they're predatory if you're
over the age of
18 get on with it get over it so Becca
TV a prominent European female streamer
and only fans creator has issued a
warning about agencies that promised to
assist only fans creators in managing
their obligations such as engaging with
subscribers many only fans creators use
these agencies due to the challenge of
personally interacting with such a large
number of subscribers Becca
TV who also used such an agency shared
her shocking experience oh I'm gonna
guess I'm not even gonna I'm gonna guess
I'm gonna guess they do most of the work
and expect most of the money and then
she later let me just let me
just she highlighted the mental toll
that being on only fans can
take shocking explain that creators feel
immense pressure to continuously perform
well and generate income okay so you
have to do things to make
money
wow wow that's so tough there is a
constant expectation to be highly
available to subscribers which can be
emotionally challenging some subscribers
have an entitled mindset believing that
they payment entitles them to unfettered
access to
creators yeah what do you think you're
selling access to
you it's like sorry I'm sorry I'm I want
I want to say sorry to the grandmothers
and the moms that are watching because
honestly guys it's been a long week it's
Friday I'm just a little unhinged I'm
sorry I'm sorry I just guys I'm so tired
I'm so tired of this stupidity um
leading to frustration when they don't
receive immediate responses and response
to these challenges Becca TV sought the
assistance of an only fans agency to
manage her workload and interactions
with
subscribers
wow that sounds so tough I just I don't
know how you survive you have an agency
that does most of the work for you and
now you're you're
whining I feel so
bad um fraud calling out a fraud you
love to see it yeah and what these women
can't do the work and so they hire
someone to do the work for them and then
about the person they hire to do
the Euro princess It's Hard Out Here
being a
woman there you have it folks tough
tough out here really really hard the
poor poor women how do we
survive how do we survive